So, it's July 16th, 2025. We are 30-ish
days out almost to the day uh to the
August 16th uh live launch.
I wrote the book because I hadn't heard
anyone talk or write anything about it
at all. And I saw it as one of the most
important things that you can put in a
business.
I am kneede um in just a bunch of
different facets of the launch. So, it's
funny because it's a, you know, it's a
few hours for everyone who shows up, but
it's like multiple years of preparation
that we're doing.
>> We're on the way to the airport, go meet
Alex and Ila for a
flight cuz content in the plane
typically does better.
>> So, I just grabbed basically every hook
that's been working for the existing
winners, plus a bunch of the organic
ones that did well.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like it just got harder cuz
they turn it off and they turn it back
on.
>> Oh,
>> I thought it was I walked in then.
>> Ain't easy being easy.
>> So, you're good just witnessing ads.
>> I was told
I'm a big clipboard guy.
>> I love
>> wildly underrated. Everybody's like,
"Let's go to AI." I'm like, "Let's print
[__] out and put it on a [__]
clipboard. You can write on it. You can
hold it. You can pass it to someone. You
can keep a couple sheets in there.
>> Never forget that.
>> You guys might want to wait to do ads
until we take off. It's going to be
>> loud as [__]
>> Yeah, Leila's been a sport, but being
not bothered by me just doing ads and
doing this BDS while she sits silently.
>> Great.
>> Yeah.
>> What do you think about the launch?
>> You think it's a good idea?
>> I think what's more interesting is
hearing what it's like to prepare for a
launch that you know that many people
are watching. I think that's more
fascinating than hearing about the book
itself.
>> Should
you change that?
>> I don't even think people would believe
it cuz like at the end of the day, I
don't think entrepreneurs like we don't
get a lot of, you know, honestly, we
just get [__] on most of the time. Like
we get told we're bad people and so I
wanted to make an event by us for us to
help solve as many of those problems I
possibly can in one day.
>> Are you sleeping?
>> No. No. No. I can tell you. Actually, I
can tell you exactly how many hours I'm
sleeping. I'll tell you my last
>> foot in death's door. I know what I'm
saying.
>> Yeah.
>> Sean says, "Old man reaper is knocking."
>> Old man mosy. 5 hours and 45 minutes
last night. 5 hours and 20 the night
before. 5 hours and 17 the night before
that. 7:45. That was Saturday. Yeah,
>> that was on my birthday.
>> Yeah, that was your birthday.
>> Well, and I love you had this tweet
that's like everyone's got battered like
no one's playing 100%. Is it kind of
like
>> Yeah, no one's playing. People are like,
"Oh, like like I didn't do I only slept
five hours last." Like [__]
>> at the volume we're doing the ads, it
sounds like it'll be
>> Yeah.
>> No red flags really.
>> We're just on standby to see what data
just says they're going to send us some
data tomorrow. So there's a little more
statistical significance. So then we'll
turn around ad creative for both
Wednesday's shoot and also the private
jet ads on Friday.
>> Yeah. I think one of the things that's
really big, like I'll I'll I'll give you
guys a little hint that I think is going
to be our our dark horse of the the many
small wins we've had up to this point.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, great. Fireworks.
I'll see you guys.
>> I wrote the book because I hadn't heard
anyone talk or write anything about it
at all. And I saw it as one of the most
important things that you can put in a
business. And so I wrote down everything
I knew about it and decided to release
it.
A lot of business owners think that they
need to change something about their
business or get into a different
business because they're not making as
much as they think they should or want
to. And a huge part of that is your
actual money model. It's your
monetization structure. How you collect
money, how you charge for what you do.
So I started writing money models in
2021. I had a mentor who told me that I
should document like the artifact or the
crystallized knowledge of that. I took
that advice and I ended up writing just
this massive tone that was 400 something
pages and uh that's what became um all
three of the $und00 million uh books and
so many models is offering the right
thing at the right time in the right way
to the right customer. And that takes a
little bit of practice but that's
exactly why I wrote the book.
right now there's just a lot of
different pieces going on. It's like
we've got inventory stuff going to
warehouses. We've got um other surprise
little bonuses that are also traveling
around the world. And I enjoy this. Like
this is the this is why most people
don't do it and this is why most people
don't win. But like I outline those
details so that it's uh kind of clear
like oh there's there's more than one
thing that happens. It's not like Alex
is just going to go on YouTube live and
be like hey I have a new book.
>> We're on our way to North Vegas to go to
the warehouse. um Money Models book
warehouse to check out inventory. Alex
on the way there right now. So yeah,
we'll see how it goes.
>> What's up?
Ready.
>> Hi there. How's it going? Thank you so
much. Appreciate it. Thanks for having
us.
>> Hello.
>> How are y'all doing today?
>> Good.
>> So, what did you guys I guess for today?
We want to make sure we hit what I know
see some of the inventory on the
>> couple pictures.
>> I mean, we're hoping to do over a
million copies. So, it's a lot of boxes.
>> We're striving very, very aggressively
to get all of the shipments out within
72 hours, which is just a herculean feat
because I think we're going to pass all
of the launch sales that we did last
time before we even release the book
this time.
>> Yeah. All right. How many How many
pallets do you guys have?
>> I'm not going to ask you to take all the
pallets down. I'm just I just want to
have an understanding.
>> Roughly about 80, I believe.
I think we just take one pallet down and
then we'll just film it and call it a
day.
>> Well, 240,000 divided by 3 is 80.
>> There's 24 in a box.
>> So, how many people will be here to like
actually move the product? What's what's
kind of the tenative plan for getting
Cuz I mean, I do that math like, okay,
10 guys. I don't know what how many how
many books a minute somebody can put
out. Um, you would know that math better
than me because last year we had 30 and
they got [__] hammered and I am five,
this will be five times bigger than last
year. Now this time we are distributing
between three different warehouses
across the US. That way we can get it to
you guys faster. We have 300 plus
support staff that are going to be here
for the launch. We have installed uh
really exceptional AI. It's just a lot.
It's a lot because we have high
standards. It really just comes down to
that. It's a lot because we want it to
be exceptional for everyone at any touch
point, any surface area that you're
exposed to at the brand. All right, so
we're opening this bad boy up.
Somebody's gonna get a a lucky uh a
lucky copy. Our goal is to get 1,800
more of these pallets of books, and
we're going to try and do it in 24
hours, which is absolutely absurd. So,
like, we're we're here, and we haven't
started promoting it yet.
>> Yeah.
>> At all.
>> From that's an email. One email. It's
one of those things that we can
definitely box up if needed. So,
>> no, I appreciate it. Thank you so much,
Stephen. So, we just got out of the
warehouse. Um, just double checking on
numbers for pallets and books and what's
going to get pre-kitted and making sure
that they're staffed up so that they can
uh handle the volume. Obviously, this is
not all the locations. This is one of
many. So, we'll have a meeting tomorrow
and centralize with leadership and make
sure that uh it's fully staffed so that
we can uh accommodate it. But, there's
always the unknown. So,
>> thank you guys for all coming.
>> I appreciate it.
>> I'm Alex Shamoszi. That's where it
starts. So, it's like I'm Alexi. This is
my 100 million book launch. And then we
like rock and roll, right?
>> Yeah. Those ads are actually already
done. Um, we finished the 40 or so that
we filmed. What I'm going to do is I'm
going to take the best hooks that are
still that will still work. Yeah.
>> The last couple.
>> Great. So, last launch there was no um
there was no offer to liquidate ad
spend. Uh and so I just printed the
money for the advertising. Um this one
I'm demonstrating the concept of the
book which is a money model. So
basically how do you pull cash forward
accelerate cash conversion uh within a
business so that you can scale and so I
want to demonstrate that with the
launch. So that's what I'm doing. And so
basically the goal is to spend as much
money as humanly possible uh while
maintaining break even or better. And
the end result should be more good
people knowing about it. So, this one
should be bigger than the last one.
We'll find out as long as ad accounts
and, you know, all that stuff works the
way, you know, we hope.
If you're struggling to get as many
customers as you want or it's costing
you too much to get customers, rather
than thinking, "Oh, I'm spending too
much to get customers, do what you can
control, make more from each one." And
so, if you want the free event and the
secret project, you only have to do one
thing. Click the link, register. I'll
see you there.
>> Cool. Cut.
>> I feel like that one's going to do what?
Yeah, that crispy.
>> I think it's possible to put a book in
the hand of every entrepreneur in
America. Books and experiences are the
two things that really changed my life.
The goal is to just have a really
awesome experience for everyone in Mos
Nation to come together and do
entrepreneur things and do it for the
greater good. Businesses rarely die of
starvation. They often die of
indigestion. Fundamentally, you need
another way to attract customers. Your
business isn't growing because you don't
have a good enough money model. When was
the last time you ever heard of a money
model? Well, you probably haven't
because no one's talking about it.
>> So, we can say we got another green dude
throwing a party. I like this, too.
>> He's going to pop off.
>> Come to the book launch August 16th.
>> August 16th.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, hope to see you there. No, you
bet. See, this is why we advertise. No
one knows. We think We think we're so
important. No one knows. And if you're
watching right now and you didn't know,
now you know. August 16th, the book
comes out. It's going to be sick. Five
mystery headliners, four amazing free
bonuses if you just pre-order, and I've
got one secret project I've been working
on for multiple years, and you'll get it
for free just by registering. I'll see
you there.